mac jones had his pro day workout
yesterday james palmer of nfl media what
in the world is that
that's landon dickerson
the army crawl behind mac jones
i i thought he was setting up the old
uh
one guy gets down
and somebody else pushes him over that
would have been you never forget the
first time that you fall for that i can
remember it vividly that feeling of just
falling and and
what is going on but uh yeah that's what
he could have done uh hey cool story
about that guy anyways with landon
dickerson he was their starting center
right he he he tore his acl in the sec
championship game he suited up for the
national championship game and they let
him take you know he snapped the ball at
the end when they were kneeling it down
to beat ohio state that's a good
feel-good story so he was out there you
know with this center yesterday that was
cool is there a way we can roll that
again because i i have an observation to
make that that may be completely
ridiculous and inaccurate you've never
done it before so don't worry no as i
see the guy crawling in i've been
watching a lot of parks and rec on
peacock yeah it kind of reminds me of
chris pratt's character
andy yeah he reminds me of andy dwyer
didn't that look like andy dwyer coming
out that's something andy dwyer would do
right that is exactly something andy
dwyer would do but it does watch it on
peak character yeah i've seen the
character watch and i will i will but it
does i see what you mean there's some
similarities there uh all right so
uh yesterday we had workouts from some
apparently they're having another pro
day as well dante smith did not get on
the scale yesterday apparently he wants
one more week to eat pizza and drink
milkshakes and otherwise bulk up right
yeah that's right uh the the the the
waffle wrapped in a stick of butter made
by homer simpson but uh mac jones did
work out yeah and and yeah i've heard
opinions all over the place i've already
falls out around one i've heard he
doesn't make it out of the top eight
uh what'd you see from him yesterday
well there's no way he's he's going in
round one i mean i don't know what
anybody could even be thinking there and
i'd be shocked if it's not in the top
15. i would be shocked listen if he went
fell to new england at 15 i would go up
no they're going to take him if he's
there at 15 new england's going he is
that their kind of guy you know you've
heard all those brady references and
everything like that you know um so
first off i think the negatives that
people are trying to talk about with mac
jones are you know it's phantom bullcrap
is what i really want to say it's just
it's over analyzation you know the one
negative all ever you ever hear is well
he's not an elite athlete like some of
these other guys okay i understand that
but his feet are phenomenal i mean
they're phenomenal in the pocket i mean
they're incredibly quick they're better
than sam darnold's work coming out in
the draft or daniel jones or you know
kirk cousins or matt ryan or derek carr
you know but i don't know why that that
didn't get mentioned with those guys but
now this it's a big deal and i you know
that's where i don't agree with that
first little sentiment about his game
now the throwing is flawless mike it's
flawless i mean
if you watch the workout at all it's
like he has a magnet to the the
receiver's chest and chin area every
ball is like boom on the money except
for one or two and again these weren't
his real receivers this is the workout
crew it probably would have looked
better if he had waddle and devonte
smith out there but i love all of this
stuff first off just showing his
footwork you know slant go scene throw
boom i mean mike it's a machine throwing
the football and it might not wow you
because you sit there and go oh it's
just lasers look at that but here's the
40 okay this is punny fast he can run
all right the film shows he can run and
get out of the pocket and throws the
ball really well on the run so again
the the things about mac jones yeah does
he look like a dork in his workout
uniform yeah he does i wish he would
dress differently but that's not where
i'm gonna drop him down 20 picks because
he doesn't look cool you know i like
this more oh here's a guy moving oh boom
oh right another on point laser perfect
spiral catchable ball right underneath
the chin of the receiver he's really a
machine mechanically and then he shows
that on the field and he's a better
athlete i think he showed yesterday too
32 inch vertical that's pretty damn good
for a quarterback you know of any
stature that's a damn good vertical and
then i think he showed the 40 there with
the four nine that you know that's punny
good too so i i think that there is no
way mac jones
lasts later than 15 with what he has put
on film and now that little workout
there i think that silence is everything
i didn't have an issue with the look at
the workout a little bit of a thicker
version of joe burrow maybe yeah right
we saw we saw the feet moving quickly
very blurring when he rolled out it's
just there's something about that goofy
uniform like andy reid and punt pass and
kick i mean there's just there's
something about it that makes it look
ungainly yes and and and and awkward and
clumsy and
he's got a square body he wears low
black cleats and then you know the white
socks on top of it right which was cool
back in 1964 when johnny unitas was
playing and bart starr but it's not
anymore right and then he tucks in his
shirt you know and yes you're right it's
not like a you know you could tell he's
not rocked up he's in shape anybody you
talk to down there in alabama and the
things i've heard is i mean the guy is a
psycho worker a psycho in the classroom
on the field he is an absolute
perfectionist you know and you know in
his uniform it's the same thing he's got
that same look yeah he's got a little
bit of a square body but the way he
wears his uniform i do think does him a
little you know injustice that way but
again that that's when that's when
people miss on evaluations because they
become biased about things that don't
matter and that doesn't look like a
football player right it doesn't look
like [ __ ] well i don't know that 30-yard
laser he threw down the seam for a
touchdown looked like a football player
i mean yeah it didn't look cool it
didn't look like aaron rodgers or my
homes i get that but the results at the
end of the day are what they are and you
saw yesterday i mean he is he's got
plenty of arm through a bunch of balls
deep posts
60 over 60 yards through one or two over
65 yards in the air he does it easy i
will continue to say
you know his arm is every bit as good as
joe burrows last year and that was not a
question for some reason this year it's
a little bit of a question with him yeah
okay
he's he's got the least
least amount of power out of the top
quarterbacks in the draft in his arm
that doesn't mean anything it's still a
really damn good arm and it's the fact
that he can throw mike
you know he doesn't have that 102 mile
per hour fastball but he can throw the
95 mile per hour fastball and put it
anywhere he wants he can just locate it
everywhere and
even when his feet are cockeyed or he's
moving in the pocket or he's got people
in front of him and he can't step in the
throat it's the same result
he can still make that so he has every
club in the bag and he has incredible
accuracy and uh there's no way i don't
think there's any way he gets out of the
top 15.
i think the things we're talking about
in his uniform i think that would make
him even more attractive to a guy like
bill belichick because he is a throwback
right right he is like a bobby lane or a
joe cap or a guy who's just going to go
out there and get it done
and doesn't look the part of the modern
robot athlete quarterback yeah and uh i
i i so there's some charm to that and at
the end of the day all that matters is
what you do with it what you do with the
ball and uh as you said if you look past
the appearance the guy can do great
things with the ball i mean
peyton manning was not an adonis right i
remember when peyton manning hosted
saturday night live he had the pecs of
an eight-year-old boy it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter no
peyton manning looks better in a bathing
suit now than he did when he was playing
you're right he's actually got looks
like he's been doing sit-ups and like
some bench press and stuff it does not
matter quarterbacks are not that way a
lot of the times they don't want to be
muscular and built that way they want to
be flexible and fluid so the ball and
the throwing motion can you know and not
be constricted by big shoulders and pec
muscles and things like that and you
know kristin throw up those stats again
you know first off we talked about the
you know and i'm not a stat guy but but
you know stats get used for some people
and then other people they just swipe it
under the rug and go uh we're not gonna
like like this one this one bothers me
too right now zach wilson there's a
concern about the competition level trey
lance who went to a lesser school
you never hear that about the
competition level it's not even a
discussion right so now last year
everyone was gushing about the greatest
statistical year ever by a quarterback
in joe burrow oh my gosh
mac jones played a tougher schedule and
had less weapons around him than joe
burrow and he broke all the damn records
you know let alone your eye tells you to
show you and go wait i don't care about
numbers what i'm seeing on the field is
real and i just think that's one that's
being people are being a little too over
analytical about and i i'm you you heard
me say it i think he's a better prospect
than tua and he's a top 10 pick
well uh that makes it a fascinating
draft especially at the quarterback
position because you've got all shapes
and sizes of quarterbacks and mac jones
is a guy who is unique in that regard
patrick certain
real quickly here uh give me your
thoughts on what he did well he's a
beast i mean he's a you know freak of
nature in a lot of ways and i'm doing my
cornerback you know safety rankings
today on my podcast so i don't want to
let let it out to where i have him but
he's certainly one of the top corners in
the draft i mean he's flawless technique
wise he's got incredible size for the
for the position to go you know six two
you know over 200 pounds and you know
everything he does as far as cutting and
moving it it's all really good you know
the thing that was a big question about
patrick certain and and is a little bit
of a you know let's say a negative or
concern is just pure speed right if
you're going to be covering guys that
run 438 then it's going to be hard to
cover them if you can't run four three
eight two now he ran low four four you
know that's good but i do like to remind
everybody 4-4 at your nfl pro day is
really probably four or five at the
combine when they do laser there is a
difference there that's why guys don't
run at the the combine a lot of the
times because they know oh when i do the
pro day it's handheld time there's a
human error factor in touching the clock
compared to at the combine where there's
a laser at the end that you have to run
through so 442 is great he's going to be
able to say i've ran that his whole life
the smart evaluators are going to sit
there and go
i'm still not sure about his top end
speed that's the big question about him
but i mean everything else is perfect
and as i say every year at this time i
didn't say it as many times this year
because there was no scouting combine
the only time you run 40 yards in a
straight line on a football field is
when something very good is happening or
when something very bad is happening the
speed and the quickness and the agility
are more relevant in a tight confined
space yes they are the most times
they're rarely in a full-out sprint and
you're definitely never in a full-out
sprint without your helmet and pads on
no which is how these guys run the
40-yard dash
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports